au fil rapatrier de force les réfugiés
vietnamiens qui continue de fuir leur
pays
c'est l'enjeu d'une conférence
internationale réunie à genève
michael gorbatchev triomphe à bonn
l'allemagne fédérale et l'union
soviétique d'accord pour tenter de
surmonter la division de l'europe la
pologne entre deux tours de scrutin les
valises à se pose pour le moment à une
cohabitation à la polonaise le sida
chacun de nous peut le rencontrer c'est
le slogan de la nouvelle campagne
d'information lancée par le ministère de
la santé
là monsieur bon soit il est l orgueil de
la marine allemande le produit le plus
abouti de la technologie du rech
en mai 41 la marine et l'aviation
britannique réussissait à envoyer par le
fond on vient de retrouver le bismarck
d'aplomb apparemment intacte à quelques
900 km à l'ouest de bresse à 4500 mètres
de profondeur un nouveau trophée à
l'actif des chasseurs d'épaves qui avait
déjà retrouvé le titanic
un monument de la seconde guerre
mondiale que nous raconte hervé brusini
de quoi s'assurer la maîtrise des mers
c'est ce que pense et adolf hitler ce
jour de septembre 1940 cuirassé bismarck
50 mille tonnes le plus gros de l'époque
vitesse maximale 32 noeuds un record
et surtout hui redoutable canon de 380
mm équipé d'un système unique de télé
pointe a de quoi faire frémir tout
l'amirauté anglaise lorsque churchill
sup le bismarck était en mer toutes les
forces anglaises furent mobilisés couler
le bismarck fait le possible et même
l'impossible avait dit l'homme au cigare
la chasse était donné une traque
impitoyable qui aboutit une première
fois le 24 mai 41
le croiseur août 45000 tonnes se
confronte à la forteresse des mères
allemandes à la cinquième salve le oud
est envoyé par le fond mais la soute à
combustible du bismarck est inutilisable
nouvelle course poursuite s'engage
lancée aux trousses du bismarck lé
prince of wales se dissimule derrière
des écrans de fumée
à quelques milles kilomètres de brest
king george et d'autres croiseur
donneront l'assaut fatal gouvernail
bloquer le bismarck tourne sur lui même
3 torpille le ferons reposer à jamais
au fond de l'atlantique il y avait à son
bord deux mille deux cents marins on
retrouvera une centaine de rescapés
aucun document d'archivé technique
n'existe sur le bismarck son système de
télé pointiage est encore aujourd'hui
une énigme la nouvelle de la découverte
de l'épave vient de réveiller bien des
appétits bien des souvenirs
l'équipe qui a retrouvé le bâtiment est
celle qui avait repéré le titanic cette
fois c'est le vestige de l'une des
grandes menaces guerrières qu'elle vient
de sortir de l'oubli
quarante six étapes participent jusqu'à
demain soir à genève à une conférence
organisée par les nations unies sur le
sort des réfugiés indochinois que faire
de ces milliers de vietnamiens hommes
femmes enfants souvent seuls qui bravent
tous les dangers pour fuir leur pays et
qui engorgent maintenant des camps qu'on
ne réussit plus à vider l'enjeu de cette
conférence est de décider ou non du
rapatriement obligatoire des boat people
le principe est celui que soutient le
secrétaire général des nations unies
encore faut-il une coordination
internationale pour éviter le
refoulement sauvage et sans garantie à
l'entrée du palais des nations vous les
voyez des réfugiés installés en europe
et aux états unis manifestent contre le
plan des nations unies la grande
bretagne qui défend les intérêts de hong
kong et pour le rapatriement obligatoire
les états unis comme la france sont
contre mais demande au vietnam de change
est quasiment de régime pour enrayer
l'exode un exode de 10 ans qui a permis
à près de deux millions de vietnamiens
de se réinstaller souvent avec succès
dans des pays d'accueil qui aujourd'hui
refusent d'en absorber davantage
jérôme owni 1978 c'est le grand exode
des boat people fuyant le vietnam sur
des embarcations de fortune expédition
souvent suicidaire voué au naufrage aux
pirates ou à une soif fatale
ces milliers de familles en détresse mve
la communauté internationale qui
décident de partager le poids de leur
accueil 2 millions en dix ans le tiers
vers les états unis
beaucoup aussi vers la france en 85 et
86 les accords états unis vietnam
permettent une émigration légale qui
dépasse l'émigration clandestine
mais aujourd'hui la question des
réfugiés de mer de chine se pose de
façon encore plus crucial quand 78 le
nombre de boat people a doublé l'année
dernière 45 mille réfugiés navigant tant
bien que mal vers des destinations comme
la malaisie l'indonésie les philippines
ou hong kong
autrefois pays de transit aujourd'hui
terminus où ils sont condamnés à
s'entasser par milliers dans des temps
faute de visa vers d'autres pays
à hong kong par exemple certains
réfugiés attendent depuis dix ans dans
les îles de soco les autorités essaient
de faire le tri entre les réfugiés
politiques et les réfugiés économiques
la situation s'est détériorée dans les
temps admet c'est officiel nous ne
pouvons pas faire face à l'afflux
d'arrivants situation bloquée les
grandes associations d'aidé humanitaire
sont découragés mission ultime pour ce
caboteur isolé le mairie racheté par un
mécène français qui consacrent 20 mille
dollars par mois aux boat people à bord
les bénévoles de l'association partage
avec les enfants du tiers monde ont pour
objectif prioritaire
une assistance aux réfugiés en perdition
réparation des moteurs accueil
temporaire soins médicaux
ses trois enfants ont été envoyés seuls
par leurs parents qui n'ont pas pu
s'offrir le voyage ils ne savent pas ce
qui leur arrive
tout ce qui leur reste une enveloppe
reçue par leurs parents avec l'adresse
de l'expéditeur aux états unis mais y
arriveront-ils à jour auront-ils même
l'autorisation d'accoster dans le camps
bondés de poules hobby dong vers lequel
l'embarcation repart seul l'espoir est
aujourd'hui à genève avec de nouveaux
visages de la communauté internationale
les deux parties la qualifie d'
historique la déclaration politique
commune signée aujourd'hui à bonn par
mikhaïl gorbatchev et le chancelier kohl
porte sur un sujet qui jusqu'ici étaient
à bout la division de l'europe lors deux
pays sont d'accord pour contribuer à la
surmonter
tout au long de la journée à bonn
mikhaïl gorbatchev a eu droit aux
ovations et aux baisers des allemands et
des allemandes en liesse
philippe profond 5000 allemands ont
scandé gorby avec nous au moment où le
numéro un soviétique apparaissait au
balcon de la mairie de bonnes avec un
sourire qui en dit long sur les premiers
résultats de son voyage gorby il faut
aller plus loin disait ses sympathisants
et gorbatchev l'a fait en signant avec
le chancelier kohl aux accords qui
touche surtout les investissements en
urss
les allemands sont séduits par la glace
nost les soviétiques sont séduits par le
deutsche mark et appelle l'industrie
allemande à s'engager en union
soviétique
la déclaration politique commune est le
reflet de ce rapprochement économique
entre bonnes et moscou un rapprochement
qui ne se fait pas sur le dos des
américains puisque les états unis sont
déclarés les bienvenus dans la maison
commune européenne berlin ouest devient
aussi le symbole de la coopération entre
l'allemagne fédérale et l'urss les deux
pays souligne aussi leur attachement aux
droits de l'homme et aux échanges
humains autrement dit les frontières de
l'urss vont s'ouvrir un peu plus
enfin cette déclaration commune réussi
le tour de force de parler du
désarmement nucléaire en demandant le
retrait de 50% des arsenaux stratégiques
des états unis et de l'urss mais en
oubliant de parler du problème des
missiles à courte portée que les
allemands se sont engagés à garder au
sommet de l'otan à bruxelles et que les
soviétiques eux veulent supprimer et à
bonn tout à l'heure le numéro un
soviétique a pour la première fois
attribué au fondamentalisme musulman et
plus seulement aux rivalités ethniques
les pogroms sanglants dont est victime
en ouzbékistan une minorité turque de
mes chèques
le premier ministre sur éthique nicolas
ryjkov a visité aujourd'hui un camp de
réfugiés il supervise lui même les
opérations d'évacuation vers d'autres
régions du pays
les massacres commis par les ouzbeks
sunnites contre les sketchs it ont fait
une centaine de morts depuis le début du
mois de juin en pologne on se prépare à
voter une seconde fois dimanche prochain
et par un artifice de procédure
le régime va présenter une nouvelle
liste de candidats la première ayant été
boudé par les électeurs dimanche dernier
comment solidarité va-t-elle gérer son
succès électoral les valises à et ses
amis sont ils prêts à participer au
pouvoir dans une forme de cohabitation à
la polonaise trop tôt répond-t-il à
gdansk à jacques melly nous on attend
qu'ils le pluralisme et tout de suite
après qu'il a fallu aller devant les
électeurs sans aucune préparation sans
programme et sans avoir le temps de
former des candidats dans ce contexte
qui était difficile de nous organiser
alors je voudrais ralentir les choses et
prendre le temps de laisser ce élaborer
des programmes socialistes chrétiens ou
communiste de manière à être prêts pour
une nouvelle étape insiste pour que
j'entre au gouvernement aux produits
dans don sans préparation baisse et
golubev au programme mais je ne veux pas
que ce serait trop de rien d'autre
est ce que pour contribuer au
développement économique vous êtes prêt
à soutenir un gouvernement communiste
sur 7
et ta pièce mais benjamin posé sur wii
mais nous serons une opposition dure si
le gouvernement et le parti ne répondent
pas aux aspirations du peuple
et si on n'avance pas dans les
propositions des mots mal à masquer des
mais si le gouvernement agit du magasin
et s'il assure une bonne gestion alors
nous allons soutenir
c'est pourquoi nous ne voulons pas
rentrer dans le gouvernement
car alors nous serions irresponsables
que c'est dans deux jours vous avez
rencontré le président françois
mitterrand qu'elle sera l'essentiel de
ce que vous lui direz qu est ce qui vous
tient le plus à coeur je lui dirai ce
que je lui ai dit quand je suis venu en
france doit si le président mitterrand
qui a débloqué la situation
certains disent que c'est par hasard
mais moi personnellement je dois dire la
vérité
après si la vérité est tel que
l'invitation du président en décembre
dernier inas a totalement fait changer
les choses
lemouchi des approches agnan il est
également depuis ce voyage qui n'est pas
qu'une nouvelle information pologne ils
vont bientôt voix chaude de saisie
présidente azzati mashaie nommé le
président mitterrand est attendu demain
var se lit pour une visite officielle de
trois jours une visite très attendue
aussi par le régime puisqu'elle devrait
signifier la fin de l' isolement
diplomatique de la pologne
en chine le régime resserre de jour en
jour les mécanismes de la répression
les militaires et policiers ont
désormais le droit de tirer à vue contre
tout rassemblement qui leur paraît
suspect et des mandats d'arrêt ont été
lancés contre une vingtaine de
dirigeants étudiants qui sont sans doute
entré en clandestinité alors on a vu
jusqu'ici surtout des images de pékin
mais comment la répression est elle
perçue dans d'autres parties du pays
notamment à caen tombe si proche de hong
kong
nous avons pu rapatrier ce reportage
une résolution lointaine à première vue
dans la ville de canton a privé demi
kilomètre de pk nous trouvons tous les
signes toutes les habitudes d'une vie
quotidienne a changé dans le plus grand
marché libre de canton aucun produit ne
manque rien au contraire une incroyable
abondance de nourriture en tout genre
devant le fait elle se presse une foule
de compte les additions premières
pousses note les journaux imprimés en
langue chinoise dagong et raconte en
détail massacre de pékin dans une
version vienne opposée à celle donnée
par la télévision officielle chinoise
la raison fantin est le deuxième port
chinois après shanghai
mais surtout il se trouve à 250 km à
peine de montpon parade le train bateau
sous la surveillance de douaniers
compréhensifs les journaux et les
cassettes des télévisions étrangères
arrivent ici puis photo pop qui est
reproduite sur place sont envoyés en
direction de tout le reste de la chine
même les téléphones ultra moderne sans
fil jouent leur rôle de canton on peut
joindre directement votre monde
les nouvelles arrivent très vite la
première impression se révèle donc
trompeuse
la révolution a quand on se cache sous
de 39 ans les semaines passent et il y à
vienne ici des manifestations et aucun
mort ni blessé
quelques arrestations seulement qui
incitent à la prudence
cette jeune fille a participé au défilé
mais elle préfère parler sans qu'on la
reconnaisse
l'état est crade sais pas mais je crois
est encore temps chalco de tout tout le
peuple et l on est en colère
nous sommes contents
mais ça me convient mais lens on va
penser que le mouvement va s'arrêter
mr oui la colère est effectivement les
universités de quand on consomme peu
ralenti la plupart des professeurs
d'étrangers sont également pas au dessus
de la bibliothèque municipale
étrangement la flamme de la liberté
assigne pourquoi pas pas de vacance du
pouvoir en argentine
le président élu le péroniste carlos
menem a annoncé tout à l'heure qu'il
était prêt à prendre le pays en main dès
la fin du mois comme le souhaite le
président sortant à houlle alphonsine
période électorale ou pas les problèmes
de l'environnement devienne prioritaire
au plus haut niveau à washington hier le
président bush présentait un plan
draconien pour lutter contre la
pollution de l'air est à paris
aujourd'hui le président mitterrand à
l'issue d'un colloque international sur
l'avenir de la planète annoncé que le
prochain sommet industrialisés à paris
et aussi la présidence française de la
cee étudierait en priorité les problèmes
de l'environnement et du développement
du tiers monde
le chef de l'état a par ailleurs apporté
officiellement son accord au projet du
commandant cousteau qui veut faire de
l'antarctique une réserve naturelle
internationale patrice pollet
l'antarctique un des endroits du monde
où l'homme n'a pas encore construit des
usines d'autoroutes ou de supermarchés
aujourd'hui le commandant cousteau
propose de sauver d'une façon radicale
ce continent en demandant son classement
en réserve naturelle à
nationale une demande pressante face
cette fois ci à la plus grande des
menaces l'exploitation du sous-sol
françois mitterrand clôturant ce matin
le colloque planète terre a apporté son
appui au commandant cousteau sa
proposition de faire du continent
antarctique une réserve naturelle
internationale me séduit je vais
demander au gouvernement français de
l'étudier de voir si en relation avec
des pays qui partagent nos
préoccupations
il sera possible de mettre en oeuvre
cette idée sans tordre et charbon
pétrole uranium
voilà ce que l'on trouve dans le sous
sol de l'antarctique 33 pays doivent en
principe fouiller dans les entrailles du
continent blanc autant de richesses qui
pourrait entraîner une certaine
pollution voir participer à la
destruction du fragile équilibre de la
faune et de la flore constaté par le
commandant cousteau
la proposition de ce matin n'a qu'un
seul but laisser aux légitimes habitants
de l'antarctique le droit d'élever leurs
enfants
tranquillement et comme on le ressent
environnement encore avec le coup de
colère du patron de peugeot-citroën
jacques calvet contre les décisions anti
pollution prise vendredi dernier par la
communauté c'est le royaume d'absurde y
déclare-t-il dans le monde à propos des
normes imposées aux voitures de petite
cylindrée réplique à l'instant du
secrétaire d'état à l'environnement
brice lalonde qui réplique donc jacques
calvet la voiture européenne sera propre
ceux qui se plaignent aujourd'hui ont
manqué de clairvoyance qu'ils s'en
prennent à eux mêmes fin de citation
environnement encore environnement et
politique cette fois avec le point sur
la campagne des européennes
à cinq jours du scrutin ce soir vu par
henri élit le style et la tactique de la
tête de liste verte en train d'acheter
rouge et le tout est dit ou presque
depuis le début de la campagne les uns
et les autres comme simone veil lui
reproche un certain daltonisme à
l'instar des verts allemands ils
confondrait le rouge et le vert
ils ont absolument c'est de constituer
un groupe vers rôle ça pour nous c'est
absolument exclu
ça signifie par conséquent que les
grenoble devront faire un peu le ménage
dans leur liste d'autres encore
notamment au parti socialiste croit
distinguer des trous dans son programme
nous avons un programme économique
seulement voilà il sort de l'ordinaire
il ne correspond pas au modèle dominant
et partant de là ils ne le comprennent
pas
un programme certes mais qui balbutie et
dont toutes les pièces ne sont pas
encore réunies
antoine waechter et les verts possèdent
une stratégie unique que l'on peut
résumer en deux points d'abord
l'écologie à tous crins résolument ni à
droite ni à gauche
ensuite la construction d'une europe des
régions qu'antoine waechter parcours
d'ailleurs entouré d'une poignée de
militants prêchant la bonne parole afin
dit-il quand 93 chacune garde intact son
identité sa culture sa langue des
régionalistes écolo qui feront sans nul
doute et pour la première fois entendre
leur voix au parlement européen comble
du paradoxe leur indemnité de député
permettront du même coup de renflouer
quelque peu des caisses laissé vide par
un succès trop rapide on va devoir
revoter à sarcelles l'élection
municipale de mars dernier a été annulée
à la demande du socialiste dominique
strauss kahn
le maire sortant et repère la montagne
fait appel devant le conseil d'état la
réforme du financement des partis
politiques le gouvernement ira plus vite
que prévu en présentant dès la semaine
prochaine deux projets de loi déjà dès
ce soir le parti communiste affirme
qu'il votera contre
le centriste pierre méhaignerie se
déclare favorable à condition d'aller
jusqu'au bout dit il
revenons aux européennes et à la
campagne qui se déroule aussi chez nos
partenaires
après l'italie hier voici ce soir le
point de la campagne en grande-bretagne
tels que la suite philippe harrouard
bref sondage dans la rue allons en gros
ils savent qu'il ya des élections
européennes ils ne sont pas certains
d'aller voter
il n'en va pas toujours la nécessité en
1984 à peine 33 % de l'électorat s'est
déplacé c'est vrai que la campagne a été
terne
ici on vote par circonscription et le
mode de scrutin favorise la
bipolarisation un seul député européen
n'appartient pas au parti conservateur
où ils sont 45 ou au parti travailliste
où ils sont 32 difficile aussi de
mobiliser les foules
lorsque le premier ministre sem à tout
vent une vie
peu positive de l'europe elle défend les
intérêts britanniques contre dit elle la
mainmise des bureaucrates de bruxelles
edward heath qui a conduit en 72 la
grande bretagne dans la communauté est
outré pour lui madame thatcher trompe
les britanniques
une chose est certaine les conservateurs
sont divisées face à la vision
thatchérienne de l'ordre pour les
travaillistes la mariée trop belle ils
ont choisi de faire de cette élection un
référendum pour ou contre madame
thatcher alors que le pays traverse des
difficultés économiques plus de 8 %
d'inflation
les sondages sont en leur faveur mais la
nouveauté ce sont les verts pour la
première fois ils sont présents dans
toutes les circonscriptions élections
européennes l'environnement c'est un des
choses plus importantes pour les gens et
nous avons maintenant disposons dans les
sondages ça veut dire que enfin les jeux
les gens se s'exprimer comme ils veulent
ils peuvent au sévère c'est vrai les
britanniques ont été plus intéressé par
l'enjeu national de cette élection
européenne
mais sont ils vraiment les seuls parmi
les 12 il a qu'une petite marque sous
l'oeil
il a remercié publiquement tout à
l'heure son siège éjectable
six jours après l'accident du chasseur
soviétique au bourget son pilote a tenu
une conférence de presse tout à l'heure
dans un lieu approprié les normes soute
de l'antonov 225 qui reste le clou du
salon
patrick esther est hélas bien sur le
vélo et hollandais la navette spatiale
soviétique
c'est sous ses ailes à l'intérieur même
de l'avion porteur antonov 225 un
véritable hangar que le pilote du mig 29
accidenté a donné sa conférence de
presse anatolie que votre jour est
manifestement en très bonne forme
physique
le visage à peine marqué par une
ecchymose j'ai d'abord pensé à écarter
l'avion de la foule dit il puis lorsque
j'ai senti le mythe plongée j'ai un
instant envisagé de sauver l'appareil en
volant sur un seul moteur mais tout a
été très vite
et lorsque j'ai déclenché le siège
éjectable j'avais déjà un peu trop
attendu
c'est vrai
la cause de la panne
eh bien je pense que le réacteur du
droit à avaler un oiseau ou un débris au
moment du décollage
et lorsque j'ai allumé la postcombustion
pour obtenir toute la puissance le
moteur droit n'a abandonné entre h en
tout ces ailettes
à partir de demain la cour d'assises des
bouches du rhône va juger jean pierre
aveline ce gardien de la paix de 29 ans
qui l'année dernière à marseille sur un
parking à bat est un homme qui avait
presque son âge et qui l'avaient pris
pour un voleur de voiture
pascal deschamps seize mois après le
drame la mère de christian 2 0 ne
comprend toujours pas pourquoi son fils
a été abattue sur un parking de
marseille
elle attend de ce douloureux procès que
toute la lumière soit faite
je me demande quelle va être la réaction
aux moyens c'est à vélines bascule
mais personnellement je l'aï jamais
rencontrée je n'ai jamais vu j'ai peur
un petit peu les stores en compte et je
sais que je vais vivre trois jours très
difficiles
écoutez de ce que je passe depuis 16
mois christian de véro est il mort ici
parce qu'il regardait avec son père une
voiture volée alors que les deux hommes
s'éloignent jean py ravine surgit larmes
au point ouvre la portière et tire parce
que dira-t-il
la victime a fait un geste menaçant une
version contestée lors de la
reconstitution par le père de christian
2 0 le juge retiendra lui l'imprudence
du policier qui par son comportement
agressif a pris des risques injustifiés
le policier impliqué dans cette affaire
expliquera et gex et j'espère qu'il
convaincra la cour d'assises que cet
acte forcément et est un acte accidentel
car sinon ce sera envisagé qu'il a agit
tel un forcené ou un cow-boy ce que son
entier dossiers administratifs dément
après 15 moins de liberté chantepie
ravine dormira ce soir ici à la prison
d'aix en provence c'est la règle tout
prévenu qui comparaît librement aux
assises est incarcéré pendant la durée
de son procès il restera donc trois
jours en attendant que le jury populaire
se prononce sur son sort
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité pour
un brigadier-chef qui avait égorgé en
appeler de 19 ans sous prétexte qu'il
avait mal repasser son treillis
ainsi en a décidé la cour d'assises de
la moselle aujourd'hui il faut souligner
la proximité de la maladie diminuer le
nombre d'inconscient le sida chacun de
nous peut le rencontrer
tels sont le thème et les motivations de
la nouvelle campagne d'information
contre le sida que lance le ministère de
la santé et que vous pourrez voir à
partir de demain sur les télévisions et
dès ce soir
quand ça marie françoise riou
quand on a en prime ainsi profiter de
notre fils quelques un choc terrible
un sentiment d'injustice
c'est pas possible c'est important de
dire mais la dissidence et lui sauver la
vie
moralement on cette maladie peut toucher
tout le monde
chaque personne peut être concerné le
sida ça n'arrive pas qu'aux autres
tel est le sens de la campagne lancée ce
matin trois spots trois témoignages
malade une séropositive et une mère
décrivent leur douleur et leur question
pour la première fois ce sont de vrais
malades qui parle pour faire comprendre
que le sida est réel est proche
alors que jusqu'à présent les campagnes
avait porté essentiellement sur les
préservatifs novembre 88 le préservatifs
préservent de tout même du ridicule
le message va passer pour l'utilisation
des préservatifs l'indicateur le plus
simple ce sont les ventes en pharmacie
et nous avons constaté depuis le mois de
novembre elles avaient augmenté de 30%
un autre indicateur c'est de voir
comment les différentes catégories
réagissent à nos messages et nous avons
constaté dans la dernière campagne que
les jeunes de 16 à 19 ans à hauteur de
60% d'entre eux déclaré qu'ils étaient
incités à acheter des préservatifs mais
l'évolution des comportements reste
lente
plus de la moitié des français ayant un
comportement à risque
toxicomanie ou homosexualité utilisent
toujours aucune protection
il va falloir pour eux aussi trouver des
mots pour le dire
revenant à l'europe avant de nous
quitter l'europe des jeunes et du
théâtre
à nanterre une cinquantaine de lycéens
allemands hollandais et français ont pu
vivre ensemble leur passion des planches
michel strelow ici philippe montoise i
ils sont lycéens ils ont entre 15 et 20
ans et leur joie et sans frontières
yoanna jean hellmuth et les autres les
voici réunis pour une expérience commune
celle du théâtre allemand
je la croyais à votre passion pour moi
rien et ceux d'un retour de flamme
sept changements chez les patients sous
la direction de metteur en scène
allemand français hollandais ils
apprennent au sein d'ateliers à croiser
leurs expériences à emprunter à
confronter leurs cultures vous effrayer
exorcisme deux groupes pour bannir toute
tension pour se rassembler par delà les
particularités pour former le cercle de
l'amitié
une manière de s'apprécier de se
comprendre par les anglais melons des
allemands fauceille on arrive quand même
tu prends les soirées dans le jardin on
va grand pas en train de chanter et de
jouer de la guitare sans cette rencontre
est importante elle nous apprend à nous
accepter avec nos différences et à mieux
nous connaître
check list cependant il ne faut pas que
cette expérience soit placée sous le
signe de l'uniformité car nous ne sommes
pas tous semblables
il faut respecter les cultures les uns
et des autres
de paris d'amsterdam berlin trois façons
de parler d'une même voix et la
sensation que l'europe se joue ici à
petit pas quelques notes de jazz
maintenant le jazz à l'honneur au
ministère de la culture ce matin en
présence de la mitterrand jack lang a
décoré quelques grands de l'histoire du
jazz dans dizzy gillespie
ils sont plusieurs à avoir joué avec
charlie parker entre autres et à rendre
hommage à guy les psys à la grande salle
de la villette à paris jusqu'au 17 juin
prochain ministre de la culture a par
ailleurs révélé le programme de la fête
de la musique qui aura lieu le 21 juin
prochain une fête à laquelle prendront
part une cinquantaine de pays cette
année
voilà très vite encore les rapports du
tiercé qui se courait à chantilly tout à
l'heure à l'arrivée le 7 le 6 et le 1 5
francs dans l'ordre rapporte 2005 110
francs et dans un ordre différent 231
francs 50 voilà dans un instant c'est
josé blanc lapierre qui va vous parler
du temps de demain christian maryvonne
au vous présentera notre dernier journal
peu avant minuit à partir de demain
matin 6h 30 rendez vous avec telus matin
très bonne soirée sur antenne 2 à demain
20 heures